quand j'étais petit je regardais la
télévision à l'époque sang noir et blanc
il y avait trois émissions que j'adorais
par dessus tout qui m'ont beaucoup
influencé finalement il y avait dit mme
dam dom daisy de galard il y avait les
raisins verts de chant christophe averty
et l'émission de benjamin castaldi et
l'émission de benjamin castaldi qui
s'appelle s'appelait déjà célébrités non
il y avait une autre émission qui
s'appelait un égal 3 c'était jacques
martin et jean yanne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah oui la spm de bouger avec qui il faut
rendre hommage à martin parce que c'est
une émission que lui avait eu c'était
c'est à lui qu'on avait demandé à man et
c'est lui qui m'a fait venir
eh ben il a eu raison parce que c'est
vachement vers un bout tout à l'heure
vous avez le nombre de fiches que j'ai
sur vous c'est incroyable j'ai jamais
autant de fiches sur ghana ne sort pas
un livre vous n'êtes pas sortir bien
alors on va commencer tout de suite par
la promo comme ça ça sera fait 1 alors
attention c'est comment on fait hacker
petite main comme les sourds-muets le
soin qui commençait pas avec les sont
diverses et sup lundi mène selon elle
changé après inventé ce que vous voulez
bien sûr surtout vous attention 1 2 3
baffie c'est bien bien alors donc jean
yanne vous publiez un bouquin qui
s'appelle le dictionnaire des mots qui a
que moi qui les connaît déjà le titre
vachement bien c'est chez plon c'est des
mots que vous avez inventé vous alors
par exemple page 25 viennent donc j'ai
noté comme ça quelques uns qui vont bien
faire et 25 à baluch free par exemple
alors une baluch riz c'est une phrase
stupide exemple la démocratie s'arrête
où commence la raison d'état cette qui
sait de main secourable
il ya phrase ou le savez ce que c'est
une phrase ou non non oui j'ai lu
attentivement le livre de jean qui est
un maître que je vénère comme henri
salvador
c'est vrai oui c'est vrai que c'est la
deuxième fois que je vois respectueux
pour quelqu'un et des dieux vivants pour
moi
donc continuez comme ça quand ça
commence comme ça on voit déjà les
chandeliers les mecs arrivent à nous
voir sapin 520m des crocs un peu oui
c'est me demande tout le temps si à la
fin il n'y a pas main qui répondent même
si je serais vous je m'inquiéterais
génial je t'admire et même quand tu
étais jeune donc rien à voir avec la
mort alors une phrase où les tâches sert
[Rires]
une phrase houle c'est un vampire se
nourrissant uniquement du sang de jeunes
filles vierges et dont l'espèce a
complètement disparu pour cette raison
évidemment c'est une phrase houle alors
après j'en ai encore ah oui j'en ai un
qui est drôle c'est inclus mieux plutôt
mou et pas très net
ça dit bien ce que ça veut dire le
travail effectué par madame cresson
pendant son séjour à la commission de
bruxelles est incontestablement du mieux
passé que des trucs comme ça c'est des
mots donc cédé moque d'eux l'a inventé
oui mais chez les mots que j'ai inventé
après la définition
ah oui c'est ça sert vous avez commencé
je vais pas commencer à prendre des
définit un ponte des mots puis à
chercher ce que ça voulait dire
j'essaie des définitions puis après j'ai
cherché quétaine mots qui correspondent
le plus à ça ouais quand par exemple il
ya it l'opel larricq l'open c'est une
réunion de personnalités désignées par
l'état pourrait assumer dans
l'audiovisuel des fonctions bien au
dessus de leurs compétences ce qui gêne
considérablement les traditions
qualifier alors vise personne évidemment
fait c'est assez
on veut tout de suite de qui il s'agit i
gr big aussi alors il gravit qu bon à
rien granic de tout le service public la
télévision française peut se vanter de
posséder le plus grand nombre d'y graver
hic si vous voulez ya un fond de vérité
au tout et tout les 10 ou 15 définition
il y en a une de bonne
c'est des mots qui risque d'être d'être
employé ça j'espère qu'ils vont être
employés
ça n'est jamais arrivé de faire quoi que
ce soit qui ne soit repris un jour ou
l'autre par un homme politique on nous
avait dit tout le monde il est beau tout
le monde il est gentil
[Musique]
et il y avait comme ça il ya des tas de
trucs qui sont entrés dans le dans la
langue il est interdit d'interdire quand
même jorian a inventé en 68 on croit que
c'est des étudiants du quartier latin
qui l'ont inventé c'est vous que
l'inventaire matin sur rtl
iny il est interdit d'interdire qui est
devenu un tout le monde croit que ça a
été fait par des étudiants gauchistes
six mois qu'il ya des gens comme vous
qui rétablisse la vérité qui agit
d'abord ça m'a coûté assez cher oui crfs
et de toi crs ss crs et ses fans maman
j'ai inventé le peuple aura ta peau
sous les pavés les frites non à dieu est
grand allah et aux enzymes
alors si vous dites que c'est un
dictionnaire qui contrairement aux
autres puissent être ouverts n'importe
quelle page pour y trouver ce qu'on
cherche pas oui parce qu'il a été écrit
comme ça
ouais à partir du moment où il a été
écrit sans sans plan et au fur et à
mesure que j'étais dans des endroits où
je pouvais pas écrire des choses très
très compliqué j'avais seulement des
petites fiches et j'écrivais des petites
notes pour moi des fois j'ai éclaté de
rire j'étais contente quand on veut une
bonne avant j'étais content et je pense
que les gens doivent le lire comme ça et
les l'idéal c'est de le mettre dans les
toilettes
à mon avis vous allez c'est ce que tout
le monde va faire alors c'est un livre
qui a été écrit dans l'est dans les
avions effectivement vous voyagez
beaucoup en fait non quand vous dites à
un moment pas 79 les toilettes des
avions d'air france sont abyss conique
oui c'est à dire qu à visco ni salle
salle voilà depuis une façon générale
tout ce qui est sûr air france est raté
alors ya les toilettes qui sont mal
nettoyé les hôtesses de l'air qui sont
des grands mères violente et les îles et
plateaux repas du son à bouche alors
éventuellement renoncer au fait de te
faire surclasser sur la nouvelle goût
des voyages vous c'est marrant c'est un
truc c'est vraiment votre passion non
mais oui mais vous dites ya une
sensation extraordinaire c'est dans un
avion finalement pire moment il ya le
pilote qui lie la votre droite c'est le
mont kenya votre gauche c'est l'île
maurice soit il c'est plaisant jeudi je
regarde toujours mal et je suis pas du
tout blasé je regarde toujours par la
panda par le hublot
non il y en a une ou deux
qu'ils se défendent pas tant les
attaques et venir c'est du reste à y
avait dans le temps avec les hôtesses
d'air france une espèce de d'habitude
d'accord tacite de joutes sur les lignes
brésilienne notamment saisi lui demande
si c'est pas aussi ouverte qui est
déguisé gens on va parler un petit peu
de vous parce que moi je connais votre
vie par caps comme je disais tout à
l'heure
dès l'âge de chupa de 13 14 ans je
regardais ouais mais là il ya des gens
qui vous connaissent pas donc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déjà première révélation de soirée jean
yanne ne s'appelle pas jean yanne jorian
s'appelle jean gougy vous avez bien fait
de changer mais pendant mon enfance il
ya eu beaucoup de l'utilisation un peu
annexes et décalé ouais et pourquoi yan
cimon prénom yann parce que je suis
d'origine bretonne gouhier ça veut dire
petite mare que c'est joli tout ça alors
vous dites que vous êtes né donc j'étais
en 33 on peut le dire et vous dites
alors quand on est en train de france et
tout farcir
il y avait d'abord tous les ans en
examen parce que le certif c'était en
deux parties le diplôme d'études
primaires en deux parties le brevet
élémentaire le bepc fameux bepc en
contrepartie si on appelait les classes
nouvelles c'est dire que jusqu'à la
guerre de vingt noms quand on est né en
tournoi on a sept ans à la guerre à ce
qu'on commence à aller vraiment de au
collège à 10 ans 11 ans et là c'était
les classes nouvelles après la guerre
donc on essayait tout en deux parties
voilà donc je me suis forcée en deux
parties et le service militaire faut
dire qu'à l'époque c'était 28 mois quand
même à 32 32
c'était à ips il ya la prison là dedans
et après tu placard yacco là non il ya
eu un petit peu de prison mais pas
longtemps parce que comme c'était la
guerre d'algérie on m'avait mis en
prison à la caserne duplex et la prison
était un peu dans sous-sol et moi je me
trompe je me pends des soupirails je
disais je suis arabe et atom torture a
coupé la machine alors les gens avaient
protesté à nous torturer les arabes
maintenant mais live entre excuses et
bientôt bond bien alors votre père était
ébéniste et ensuite lithographe our
little
c'est un procédé heureusement que vous
êtes là comme ça je vais corriger de
niche mais il faisait des lithos de
benjamin rabier ça c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai mais justement où bonne question
benjamin rabier c'est le type qui avec
cas des 6es la vache qui rit quand même
c'est pas grave c'est vrai oui votre
mère était couturière
oui chez madeleine vionnet et chez
lanvin
oui juste vous allez au lycée chaptal
diaconesses sur vos lycées chaptal c'est
bien voir s'ils connaissent avic l'école
de journalisme vous avez été virés vous
êtes parti non je suis j'ai pas été
jusqu'à la fin j'ai pas été viré je suis
pas parti c'est à dire que les deux
premières années c'était le l'école
normale et à partir de la troisième
année c'était les techniques de la
presse donc là sa demande était un peu
l'imprimerie l'école estienne tout seul
servi et bien de journalistes mais pas
humble et narquois la semaine et alors
là après la guerre vous rencontrez
quelqu'un qui s'appelle bob du parc à
saint germain il s'appelle bob du pack
de marsily du gab et de toy non tachées
d'encre
je serai pas assez de place sur la fiche
pour tous marqués non ce qui est génial
c'est que là vous faites vous commencez
à faire du cabaret et vous faites un
cabaret rue de rivoli d'histoire insensé
qui s'appelle l'académie des vins alors
expliquez nous parce que là il y avait
des gens qui venaient
les cartes non c'était il y avait un
cabaret qui était rue de rivoli qui doit
s'appeler le slow club maintenant qui
est au 2eme vois bien une affiche en est
à la deuxième étage en tout seul et le
pâton et la patronne avait trouvé un
truc c'est que c'est qu'il y avait des
cars qui faisait la tournée des grands
ducs à paris dont il reste au lido à
pigalle et il fallait une cave saint
germain des prés mais c'était très dur
de se garer à saint-germain-des-prés
c'était beaucoup plus facile de se garer
à rue de rivoli et comme les touristes
n'y voyait que du feu
l'écart arrivée à saint germain des prés
et nous on avait fait un spectacle qui
était qu'ils n'avaient pas de début
qu'ils n'avaient pas de seins savait pas
d'importance puisque quand le car arrive
et en os ont sonné les types descendait
le spectacle était commencée et au bout
de quelques temps le guide leur disais
bon bah c'est terminé pour partir et ils
partaient donc ça sera fini et alors il
fallait vraiment accrédités
saint-germain-des-prés celle que vous en
faites vous jouiez le temps oui bon ok
c'était la tuerie chatel après que dix
enfants au lido et alors on avait en
nous alliant un moment mais il faut
quand même que ce soit plus saint
germain des prés alors on a trouvé un
mec qui ressemblait à sartre on l'a mis
dans un coin avec un bloc il l'écrivait
gilles massa c'est jean paul sartre a
fait
jean yanne entre dans le chenil le show
business est engagé aux trois bonnets
par jacques canetti après un service
militaire et là faut reconnaître que
vous avez une bonne gage vous étiez
chargé du costume soul ou lyon c'est
vrai ça c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai le
mec qui fait les filles c'est moi qui
fais mes filles
c'est vrai c'est moi qui fais mes filles
simplement vous avez dû le déclarer vous
avez vu les gars et un jour âgées aux
étiez plus étanche et que j'avais dû le
dire le service militaire je faisais le
costume du loup alors j'étais jeune j'ai
fait mon service militaire dont pour la
première partie phase militaire au
service historique de l'armée
oui mais quand on est au service
historique de l'armée on n'écrit pas
forcément l'histoire des jupons et
l'histoire du vêtement soulignant qu'il
n'était pas fou de l'armée non j'étais
au service torride armée où on classait
toutes les choses qui concerne l armée
et toutes les choses militaire une
galerie ça nous permettait de continuer
à vous occuper de vos activités
industrielles des loisirs
bon alors là c'est l'époque des cabarets
alors ça dit plus rien à personne
aujourd'hui les cabarets l'amiral club
55 fait des trucs plus personne ne sait
ce que c est alors à l'époque vous
faites vous rencontrer jacques martin
ont fait cette émission mythique qui
s'appelle un égal 3 on va voir
d'ailleurs un sketch que j'oserais dire
avancer que j'ai reçu un email d'un
dénommé laurent picone qui est un
français qui habitent en hollande et qui
me dit ma femme et moi on a décidé de
faire un enfant
et de l'appeler serge et quand l'enfant
sera né en lui offrira un chien et on
l'appellera manier tout
[Applaudissements]
tu verras ce que tu voudras fredo mais
dans cette année gros de beethoven et
ben on sent encore vachement n'influence
de mozart pour dire que c'est la période
charnière de l'évolution beethovénienne
je suis d'accord avec toi mais c'est
plus sensible dans l'allée grande dans
la région en filigrane dans le fait
c'est sa deuxième manière à beethoven
c'est du bac c'est du passé
produire sur elle
les petits jouent le
c'est françois janvier ouais ça vraiment
prendre un bain turc connaît pas la
taille c'est adrian flandin son bien il
joue plus délié dans les aigus samedi
dernier jeu nous vendait les mômes à
saint louis des invalides pour entendre
du pressage et bien du froid est la
mieux de bien du froid ils veulent quoi
moi je trouve qu'il a une bonne
persistance rythmé doigt mais tu as
sincèrement il joue bien mais il sait
pas servir de la deuxième viole de gambe
sat et paul allard registre à sont au
dessus mais quand il a un peu
d'instruments comme ans qui se défend je
vais lire un petit
[Musique]
c'est cette curée
peggy et bébert jeu serait chouette tu
sais ce que c'est tu ferais tu mounir
est un peu tôt
ouais je suis le roseau de rester dans
le désert de la chrétienté
je suis là triste fleurs flétri sous le
par des païens je suis la colombe qui
chante dans la chapelle du créateur
je suis le cri d'amour de l'occident
[Musique]
ça ne va pas tomber dit tu sais mais
j'ai choisi le passage le plus mince ou
peut paraître ce que je vois plus clair
à lui-même
j'oriente y est bien aussi pour la
grippe là il ya eu aussi le permis de
conduire qui est très connu qui était en
latin que tout le monde connaît le
permis de conduire est alors en 64 ya eu
un sketch
alors là vous avez une histoire terrible
c'est un sketch élevé napoléon qui
faisait une course cycliste avec ses
généraux un c'est lui qui vous a fait
virer celui-là ou non non non celui qui
nous a fait virer non non non celui qui
nous a fait virer c'est une
mais c'est un sketch il passé dans une
église et où moi j'étais en train de
mettre des fleurs sur l'autel et puis
martin entré en moto et un rosier
s'était baptisé corey et martin me
déshabillait et ils me le faisaient du
gringue ils baissent m à salopette
s'agit là ça a été dur et puis un autre
truc aussi où je faisais choix de faire
jouer viens poupoule alors là ça n'est
plus tellement aujourd'hui
alors voilà donc ça donc moi ça a été
pour moi fondateur je pense pour
beaucoup de gens aussi et en 65
rencontres et claude chabrol et vous
faites des films très important au fait
le boucher la ligne de démarcation que
la bête meure en fonction des films très
important
godard vous faites week end il un film
aussi très important et puis après ça
s'est un petit peu gâté mais vous dites
tout le monde croit que j'ai joué des
navets puis après les bons films en fait
vous avez commencé par les bons films
beau j'ai commencé sur des bons si j'ai
fait des navets après ouais c'est ça
mais j'ai fait les navets avec une
certaine volupté
c'est pas parce que il m'a pas engagés
dans des banques en est la preuve
je trouvais ça bien le faire des films
séries qui après les navettes a refait
des bons films j'avais bien son art
exemple vous savez à cette époque là les
les comiques faisait très peu de temps
dans les films d'harry cole faisait une
demi-journée dans nos fans et ça
suffisait pas ce que les gens allez le
voir il entend des rovers
qu'est ce que raconte le caillou les
gens étaient ravis alors tous les tous
les gens qui faisaient des films voulait
avoir au moins une demi-journée ou une
journée d'alcool et moi j'étais avec
francis blanche et nous on nous mettait
tout le temps dans le fond il y avait
des scènes qui se passait dans les films
n'importe n'importe où et nous on
parlait et on faisait les métèques on
était au bar et on parlait et alors le
metteur en scène visée alesi parler ou
alors on parlait alors bon quand on sait
plus quoi dire on avait un code et on
disait je suis catholique comme vous
c'était la langue française il a je suis
fatigué hier j'ai mangé traque mon
cousin était très difficile et puis je
suis rentré tard la maison et puis moi
je vais vous dire je suis catholique
comme vous alors je savais qu'il irai
plus rien il fallait que j'enchaîne
alors j'ai mais qu'est-ce que vous
rapportez de plaisanterie facile
moi aussi je jusqu'à ce que je ne
supporte plus rien et moi aussi je
t'attends de chercher parce que quand tu
y as là c'est un truc qu'on trouvera pas
parce qu'évidemment ça a été foutu à
poubelles mais c'est la même chose qu'il
ya six à huit prises et a eu un prix
différent et des ja mais une chose est
ce que vous croyez vous êtes un grand
acteur est ce que vous croyez que c'est
un grand acteur parce que vous prenez ça
par dessus la jambe
non non pas du tout je la mange
je devrais pas dire surtout à la
télévision française devant des
milliards de gens dans le monde qui
parle français croyait pas si bien dire
que je suis un grand acteur j'ai dit si
ces noms c'est que c'est un grand acteur
si je remercie beaucoup
je longe dit simplement je suis un
acteur plausible c'est dire je n'ai
jamais fait une chose qui me paraissent
pas plausible un bon si on me demande de
faire un vétérinaire
je connais des vétérinaires qu'on ma
tête mon allure mon correctement je peux
faire un vétérinaire
si on me demande de faire un camion je
connais camionneurs pour mon allure donc
emportements je peux conduire un camion
si on me demande de faire un pianiste
romantique avec george sand là je fais
pas c'est que je peux pas faire l'aiglon
ouais alors quand vous avez le prix à
cannes le prix d'interprétation pour pia
là pour nous ne vieillirons pas ensemble
un film remarquable vous alors tout le
monde vous admire tout le monde chante
vos louanges et vous vous dites moi il
suffisait que je baisse les yeux pour
voir l'air triste jeu baisser les yeux
pour regarder mon texte en fait l'essai
pense-bête partout dans la voiture et
tout le monde crie au génie
oui mais je peux plus le faire parce que
je vois plus clair alors avant je
pouvais baisser les lieux lire mentec
son faux cul et on disait il est triste
maintenant si je dis tu sais j'ai de la
peine eh bien
ok comme vous il ya un mec qui était
comme mousse était chancelier adenauer
parce que lui c'est pareil vous dites on
a toujours cru qu'ils étaient vachement
sérieux à l'anneau vert avait une
blessure était chancelier allemand après
la guerre c'est le premier chancelier
allemand alors il a une blessure de
guerre qui lui a coupé les zygomatiques
et les zygomatiques ils sont de chaque
côté du stage je sais pas comment il a
pu prendre un éclat d'obus double qui
lui a coupé les deux mais ils n'auraient
pas ils pouvaient pas faire autrement
il ya un mec qui fait ça mieux que moi
dans le dans la dans la lecture des des
textes c'est brando ouais bravo ils
touchent pas une bille value n'est
jamais son texte quand il a fait
apocryphes you know
il devait sortir d'une grotte et on
pouvait la scène était filmée d'un
bateau qui était sur la rivière donc on
pouvait paraître un prompteur on pouvait
pas mettre quelque chose pour qu'ils
lisent
alors on a dû mettre son texte de
l'autre côté de la rivière il a fallu
mettre un texte de 20 mètres de haut
soit panneaux gigantesques dans les
crises son texte à la bombe et vous vous
dites plus je souris plus j'ai l'air
triste
je défends vous dis souris sourit c'est
vrai voilà tout le temps envie de vous
dire pourquoi faisait pas l'air content
souriez souriez pour voir là il ya une
main
[Applaudissements]
quand vous dites a finalement qu'être
acteur ben oui c'est comme un cordonnier
qui a pris à réparer des chaussures
depuis l'âge de 19 ans et qui connaît
bien son métier on lui demande pas
d'être passionné quoi on a le sentiment
vous faites ça comme ça vous faites très
très bien mais avec une espèce de
distance je crois que c'est le principe
même du
du bon travail c'est à dire que on n'a
jamais on ya ya pas d'oscar de la
plomberie
non on contrôle et il n'y a pas de n'ya
pas de gens qui se félicite corporatives
mans 1 longueur de journée comme nous
bon je sais que ça vous a beaucoup
touché d'avoir le 7 d'or puisque j'ai vu
des larmes couler sur vos jours mais bon
vous vous rendez compte il y avait les
sept d'heures de la pâtisserie comme les
camionneurs ça c'est comme les routiers
fébrile viendrai pleurer
et alors là vont continuer la vie de
jean yanne qui est passionnante
là
alors au delà de cette mélodie qu'on
connaît tous il faut savoir que tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil et est le premier film anti pub
anti société de consommation anti radios
commerciales
les mecs il vous fait des bd des années
60 avec dédé des années 60 absolument
c'est à dire que les mecs ils bouffaient
enfin vous avez vu le film les mecs film
culte il vous fait des concerts j'étais
couvert de boutons dans la radio le mâle
20 ouais alors aujourd'hui un mouvement
vous savez ça qui s'appelle les casseurs
de pub vous connaissez les casseurs de
pub non les casseurs de pub c'est un
mouvement de résistance à l'agression
publicitaire iad journée sans achat ray
au jour d'hui c'était la journée de 25
ans aujourd'hui c'est la journée sans
achat aujourd'hui pour acheter
aujourd'hui ils ont fait un acte
criminel parce que c'était aujourd'hui
la journée sans achat et un dehors du
souvenir proposer des [ __ ] et donc la
publicité il dit ça ramène l'être humain
au rang de produit 10 la pub ou bastia
lise la pub c'est du totalitarisme soft
vous pensez ça aussi nom de temps en
temps la pub est d'abord rigolote c'est
vrai il ya des trains marrante et puis
ça montre simplement qu'il ya des gens
qui ont des idées de temps en temps
c'est irritant
parce que l'on ment et là on le sait
comment il s'étend des temps parce que
la plupart du temps on ment pour les
produits pas chers donc on ment aux
petites gens
si le mec il dit mme fait de la
publicité pour une robe du soir à 80
mille balles et qui dit regardez comme
ce serait une princesse diana une
princesse un bois à broder bon bah ça va
venir mais c'est surtout les petits
produits quand les petites des petites
choses qui risque d'avoir les
grands-mères et ça c'est pas ça c'est
pas très bien cela dit la pub ça permet
à plein de gens de faire le ce qui
n'existe plus maintenant c'est le court
métrage
ouais parce que dans le cinéma il ya
plus beaucoup de courts métrages de fer
continue calanques à la pub c'est une
bonne école parce qu'il faut être
efficace
croyez vous encore qu'une croissance
infinie est possible sur une planète où
les ressources sont limitées
le samedi 25 novembre c'est la journée
sans achat alors faites un geste pour la
terre
arrêtez d'acheter voilà le journal donc
casseurs de pub ça existe des états unis
il s'appelle adbusters
il ya tout un mouvement comme ça de
citoyens contre la pilosité une journée
sans pognon aussi vrai ça serait drôle
pas mal à l'aise alors vous êtes quand
même très branché pognon dont on a
apprécié en chine iran chez poney on a
l'impression quand même que vous avez
comme ça toute votre vie vous avez un
peu couru après l'argent soit regardé
des mythes des catholiques comme les non
bien sûr que je suis moche et pognon et
c'est comme laisser comme les rôles
c'est vrai on dit par exemple
moi j'ai dit ça plusieurs fois je dis je
on reçoit sur son scénario on m'a dit
vous serez en costume de lin blanc sur
une plage avec une très belle jeune
fille qui va vous servir des pompes et
puis un mec qui va vous éventé derrière
et vous allez poser votre main d'un sac
de loukoums et l'autre main sur un bon
c'est plus un verbe que d'aller tourner
germinal dans le
dans les corps donc les forfaits
forcément c'est plus agréable de gagner
de l'argent qui est pas en avoir
mais c'est plus agréable dans des beaux
endroits que dans des endroits pour
mieux c'est plus agréable de bien manger
que manger de la merde et aptes à ce
propos voudrait tant les d'une compagnie
aérienne
alors vous êtes vous êtes un peu ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui un bobo vous
excuser un bobo c'est un bourgeois
bohème ça c'est des gens qui ont des
idées de gauche et qui aime bien confort
de droite
ouais bah oui s'il non mais j'ai pas
d'idée de gauche ah bon avant vous
disiez que vous aviez des idées de
gauche s'ils avaient des idées un peu
gauche mais c'est maintenant presque
avant avant quand même il disait j'ai
décidé maintenant non non je suis dire
qu'à une certaine époque les idées de
gauche c'était facile à déterminer
tandis que maintenant les idées de
gauche quelle différence y attendiez
gauche et lili descente où son économie
de marché même vin dont ils sont tous
sur la mondialisation
alors vous êtes un jeune papa vous avez
quel âge il à votre enfant de neuf ans
neuf ans vous avez changé d'avis parce
que ça les années 70 mais j'ai retrouvé
une déclaration sur les enfants étaient
terribles les enfants je les déteste
réussir un mariage c'est difficile mais
si on rate ça peut s'arranger un enfant
raté ce ne s'arrête jamais si j'en avais
eu j'aurais pas la patience de m'en
occuper et si des fois j'avais la
patience je lui inculque aurait que des
notions qui ferait lui à malheureux si
on ait eu un qui maintenant est grand il
ne m'en suis pas occupé beaucoup et
occupe maintenant n'aurions ce faire les
enfants quand on est vieux
d'abord parce qu'on y en a pas longtemps
[Rires]
c'est entendu ces jeunes quand on a
besoin vivent bien c'est vraiment parler
et embêté par des mots mais c'est vrai
quand on est vieux on a le temps de s'en
occuper
vas-y en poupe on sait bien que vous
avez une vraie philosophie des ducs ont
fait dites moi vous pensez quoi jean
yanne de jean pierre bacri parce que
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu votre
successeur dans la non il a un côté vous
avez comme vous voyez cette espèce de
jeu parce j'aime l'amour que vous m'ont
tous les cas il fait scruté comme ça
complètement et oui ben oui oui le
prison trois ours mal léché
oui mais ça va tu vous en faites votre
grand plaisir c'est de bouffer à poil
tout seul dans la cuisine non ça dépend
un peu beauf est à poil avec quelqu'un
d'autre je te dis ici on lui arrive
d'être amoureuse bien léché aussi c'est
vrai que là
elle est la solitude n'est ce pas est un
taux qui m'a toujours épaté quand j'ai
vu des bons peut-être qu'il ya des gens
malheureux et qui sont encore plus
malheureux parce qu'ils sont seuls mais
la solitude ne m'a jamais paru est une
chose dramatique parce que l'on est
tellement bien quand on est tout seul
bouya juste le perroquet qui vous pris
fin peu l'épaule le perroquet maintenant
il va bien parce qu'il a une copine et
vous emmerde mois alors il faut être
papa dans la cuisine là il va vous
arriver un truc terrible ch il te plait
[Musique]
jorian nous allume faire de la radio
vous avez voulu faire de la télé vous
avez voulu réaliser des films j'ai voulu
faire des affaires d'une société de
tournage de films français aux états
unis et chine america en france vous
avez voulu faire la décoration d'hôtel
mais si vous aviez choisi d'être que
acteurs pensez pas qu'aujourd'hui vous
seriez un des premiers acteurs du monde
seulement un coeur parce que c'est pas
moi qui ai choisi d'être acteur c'était
pas mon c'était pas mon truc moi je suis
voulais faire partie du spectacle et
surtout je voulais écrire des choses
comme des formes demande on me dit mais
qu'est ce que vous regrettez le plus je
dire je regrette simplement que pendant
des années on mais on n'est pas demandée
l'écrire les dialogues parce que j'étais
persuadé que je serai un bon dialoguiste
michel audiard c'est sûr ils gardent le
disais les études vrai qu'on dirait mais
les gens voulaient pas mais je dis ça
sans aigreur puisque j'ai fait d'autres
choses plus lucratives
ouais mais pour moi acteurs c'est pas le
truc évidemment qui me passionne le plus
et si c'était à refaire vous referiez la
même chose j'étais suspect refaire je
referais la même chose dans les grandes
lignes
c'est dire que je met par exemple je
ferai beaucoup plus de choses dans la
décoration ou beaucoup plus de choses
dans l'urbanisme où beaucoup de plus de
choses dans des choses comme ça n'arrête
tandina physique pas trop dans la
musique je passais bien tu crois c'est
vrai j'aurais adoré travailler avec avec
des urbanistes aimé partie du projet
brasilia ouais tout ce facteur qua non
pas tous aux facteurs mais on est
toujours acteur de quelque chose dans
une société qui vous entourent on allait
mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien dorian là vous publiez le
dictionnaire des mots qui a que moi qui
les connaît voilà du mouvement gay
ressent une gêne
vous êtes le meilleur public du monde et
on vous a vu le nombre jeu le nombre de
jeunes
c'est bien jean vial le nombre gonzesse
qui alla est là il ya pratiquement libre
service et impôts qu'ils calment un peu
ma mort je vous faire une interview
dicko mais avant il ya quelques emails
intéressant laurent volution alors il ya
un mec qui m'a dit il écrit un truc qui
lie la fille vit qu'il faut bouger
pendant le jingle mais pourquoi sur
canal pendant une heure et demie
bougeait pas quelle mémoire il est alors
il ya le chien bien le chien kiki dont
la photo apparaît sur l'écran
le chien qui qui a été abattu par son
propriétaire
parce qu'ils bougeaient pendant le
jingle alors tingle et jean rien
[Musique]
du
espérons que samuel ne subissent pas les
mouvements d'un fils samuel ne subisse
pas le même sort que qu'équipé voit-on t
shirt samuel oui ces paroles réveillon
[Applaudissements]
le nombre d'e-mails 4e soins tous les
ans chez sun est un petit coup c'est
rigolo
j'aime donner la définition jeu voisard
les yeux fermés impôts comment ce site
par un gros mot way escroquerie
fondamentale arrêts oui c'est ça
attention amour oui imposture avez-vous
pensé ça oui non c'est la mèche non je
dis c'est la même chose que les impôts
il ya des gens qui peuvent pas voir bien
qu'arrivée de leurs oeuvres et puis à
des gens très riches qui peuvent en
avoir beaucoup parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
iota c'est pareil il ya des gens qui
peuvent avoir beaucoup du yacht à neuf
alors ça si c'est l'un des contes que
dans le dico il ya me ça c'est un truc
formidable il faut saluer à un rêve
parce que dans le nouveau petit robert
il a il il ya depuis longtemps un
certain nombre de deux mots ayant
notamment 9,9 étoffes et ça c'est quand
même les fourguer sa drogue ça c'est une
belle chose c'est extraordinaire ça ce
n'est pas dans le dictionnaire de
l'académie française c'est pas dans le
belge spe et les académiciens sont
jamais l'acteur faisant jamais couché
une moche ils ont pas peur des cas
baston bat en battant mais vous dis tout
le temps vous je suis pas battant dès
que ça devient un peu dur je m'arrête
c'est vrai que moi je suis pas un fan de
l'escalier quand il ya un ascenseur
[Rires]
j'en prends moi je prendrais chez vous
maintenant qui est très très bien c'est
que le bar bruxelles c'est ce que c'est
un clébard falloir un club art c'est un
goût c'est artificiel obtenez à la suite
d'une intervention chirurgicale et
consistant à créer une petite poche sous
l'abdomen des fervents du nudisme pour
permettre de conserver leur carte de
crédit et quelques billets de banque sur
eux lorsqu'ils sont nus sur la plage
aurait toujours des phrases comme dans
le robert des exemples nus sur le sable
nous nous amusions à lutter soudain une
douleur fulgurante ne transperce a sans
le faire exprès mon compagnon de jeu
alors forcé son pouce dans mon club et
il est pas mal soudain il est très très
loin du c1 du ces c'est un jeune animal
très
et sautillant mais oui qui se promène
dans la campagne
en faisant des cui cui miaou la raison
c'est un car je reçois maintenant jean
yanne pour la parution au cherche-midi
de ses pensées répliques texte et
anecdotes et chez plon des sketches
joués et non jouer à jouer ou injouable
bonsoir
lauriane vous dit que quand tout le
monde tout le monde me jette des fleurs
comme ça c'est mauvais signe je me méfie
quand l'unanimité mais rate je me frotte
les mains c'est à dire qu'en ce moment
vous êtes plutôt dans une période
effectivement où tout le monde
après vous adore vous avoir dans ses
émissions de télévision danser c'est
dire que je me méfie un peu parce que je
commence à prendre de la bouteille et
tout ça ça fait un petit peu dernier
romain jouan
je me dis que pour pourvu comme
téléphone pas pour avoir un césar en
lançant finalement laon césar d'honneur
voilà le césar d'honneur c'est sûr qu'on
est cuit l'année d'après attendait ouais
vous dites dans votre bouquin
l'ajustement au cherche-midi
actuellement je suis tête d'affiche au
cinéma tout le monde se préoccupe de
savoir si j'ai faim ou froid dans
quelque temps si ça se trouve personne
au gramme de l'article métro et même un
ciel gris à l'entendre il ya longtemps
ça fait partie des pensées d'avancé
c'est des trucs qui ont été pris sur
tout l'ensemble de des conneries que
j'ai pu dire pendant des années on a des
bonnes et il y en a des éléments
indépendants vont en parler mais enfin
je veux dire à l'époque c'est vrai et à
une certaine époque que j'étais
considéré comme le petit génie parce
qu'il y avait eu des prix des vaches un
des récompenses qu on avait fait
beaucoup de sous avec le cinéma et je me
disais si ça se trouve personne ne me
donnant un ticket de métro il sait pas
aller jusqu'au ticket de métro et un
moment où bien sûr tout le monde
alors vous dites parfois vous dites page
33 une définition de vous qui est je ne
suis qu'un obscur anna un peu pourri
alors on va parler de vous on va parler
de vie et puis au fur et à mesure de
notre conversation retrouvera certaines
de ces certaines de ces de ses pensées
de ses répliques anecdotes et autres
textes
alors simple et jean bouyer vous êtes né
en 1933 aux lilas c'est un bled les
lilas soumettre l'île alors c'était un
quartier nous les lilas c'était
dans une petite bourgade assez mignonne
avec des lilas avec avec avec des bois
c'était au dessus de nogent et y avait
aux lilas beaucoup de petites maisons de
petits pavillons et maintenant comme
partout c'est devenu une espèce de
l'aider bricorama plutôt maintenant les
deux de grands ensembles le chien comme
pas alors pas commencer votre père était
dennis lithographe ensuite déçu du front
populaire c'est peut-être ça qui vous a
donné d'ailleurs cette vous vous dites
que si vous êtes lucide c'est pour ça
que cet optimiste parce qu'en fait quand
on est lucide on s'aperçoit qu'il a rien
de grave
oui pas déçu du front populaire je dire
que ça j'avais fait c'est pareil une
espèce de préface enfin on m'a demandé
de faire une bibliographie pour une
sortie de films et j'ai fait la
bibliographie par moi même donc c'est
quand j'ai dit effectivement que je suis
ni en 33 qui est là le toit probablement
une des années les pires parce que on
sait tous farsi quand on est né entre
1,6 entre on avait six ans 39 et après
pour ce qui concerne les études par
exemple moi j'ai tous les ans j'avais un
examen parce que je me suis tapé le
diplôme d'etudes primaires préparatoire
en deux parties donc 6 et 5
après le certificat d'études en deux
parties après le brevet élémentaire
entendent tout était en deux parties
après en plus on est passé au service
militaire on a été maintenant en plus on
a fait 28 voire éventuellement avait pas
qu'alors je passe sur votre vie avant la
célébrité disant turgot lycée turgot
chaptal l'école de journalisme et de
virer de l'école de journalisme non non
la rue d'origine non non non non j'ai
pas été viré je relis gtc on y avait une
vraie deux corps y avaient juré ouais on
était on était pas mal mais simplement
on est parti je crois qu'on a tous fait
pareil je sais pas il faudrait que
demande un jour affirme je vois tous les
jour j ai demandé moi je suis parti à
partir du moment où on a commencé à
faire des techniques de l'imprimerie ça
je m'en foutais comme de l'an 40 parce
que je voulais être journaliste et voir
comment c'est fait voilà il y avait des
cours à l'école estienne machin alors
après ça donc vous commencez au cabaret
le premier votre premier partenaire
j'ai retrouvé sa en préparant votre
interview s'appelait botte du pack
levier rencontré à saint germain oui
vous êtes j'ai été auditionnée par
rapport à jacques canetti dont on parle
au moins une fois par semaine dans cette
émission ce qui me fait plaisir
il faisait commencé aux trois baudets
avec 7 avec liszt avec vous je sais pas
chez au début peuvent du parc était
revenue d'indochine oui s'était occupé
du théâtre aux armées j'ai rencontré à
saint-germain-des-prés il cherchait des
gens pour écrire des sketches alors j'ai
dit bon j'ai écrit des sketches et après
il cherchait des gens pour les jouer et
puis un jour il ya les acteurs qui est
qui a fait défaut donc je les remplacer
du pack m'a dit il faut que tu aies joué
parce que c'est bien et la première
chose qu'on a fait c'était un spectacle
dans laquelle est mis des vins qui était
une boîte de la rue de rivoli et on a
marché parce qu'on préparait sa bannière
des invalides non c'est pas ça c'est
qu'on avait passé un accord avec les
gens qui venaient avec des carrés on
faisait un spectacle qui n'avaient pas
de début et pas de faim parce que les
touristes rentrait en plein spectacle il
y avait une sonnette et deux étages
quand on sonnait on se mettait à jouer
et puis après l'organisateur vous faut
aller au lido maintenant alors tout le
monde sortait nuançant laquelle on
faisait 5 6 fois ça et après j'ai fait
sharp
il ya eu toute cette époque
effectivement du cabaret vous écriviez
des chansons d'ailleurs parallèlement
philippe clay line renaud
il ya eu effectivement de monter sur
scène à l'amiral à la fontaine des
quatre saisons galerie 55 etc et c'est
là que vous avez connu devos roger
pierre et jean marc thibault fait des
vignes mais quelque chose qui se passait
à cette époque-là au cabaret les poiret
serrault il est plein de choses comme ça
il y en effervescence dix ans il y avait
des cabarets nir déjà c'était j'étais
pas longtemps apanage hier donc pas
longtemps après la guerre les gens à
voulait rigoler ouais donc il y avait
plus de ça il y avait beaucoup de
beaucoup de cabaret et en plus il y
avait un l'habitude de sortir c'était
pas très cher le cabaret les gens
allaient boire une bouteille le soir en
écoutant des rigolos alors que
maintenant il risque est très peu
d'endroits mais c'est dommage quand on
voit des comics qu'on puisse pas boire
un coup alors avant bon à l'amiral
c'était un cabaret les gens buvaient la
case la rs 55 ans buvaient l'échelle de
jacob en bus verts a parlé ici avec ce
héros et des mots j'aime bien c'était
cette époque
en 58 fait votre premier disque avec
eddie barclay en 61 vous entrez en
europe et numéro 1 à l'époque avec
gérard cyr là vous faites cette émission
moi qui m'a profondément marqué dont on
parlait tout à l'heure un régal 3 avec
martin il ya des sketches dans le
bouquin de ski et chez plon les sketches
joués dont jouer injouable il ya les
fameux sketch de l'époque c'est-à-dire
le permis de conduire
les embarras de circulation en europe
j'ai pas comment il s'appelle
enfin c'était des grands classiques
maintenance avec laurence trier ce n'est
pas tout ça c'était ses grands
classiques vous avez été comme on l'a
dit tout à l'heure
embêté pour le skate sur napoléon en
sorte on a parlé et vous commencez entre
temps vous commencez le cinéma premier
film la vie à l'envers jy suis à quelque
chose comme ça il est venu j'ai su à est
venue à la gare et 55 où je passais en
faisant des monologues et 65 vous
rencontrez le chabrol j'avais fait avec
lui quand même trois grands films qui
resteront dans l'histoire du cinéma il a
ligne de démarcation le boucher que la
bête meure en 67 week-end avec godard
mine de rien et alors on singe access
gateway
c'est là que ça se gâte parce que tout
le monde le dit vous avez joué des
navets puis après vous avez rencontré
godard c'est le contraire sûr j'ai
d'abord rencontré cela et après j'ai
fait des non chasseurs alors en 68
alors si j'ai vu ça dans votre bouquin
il ya toutes vos phrases tout vous
saillie disons et il est interdit
d'interdire page 90 c'est vous qui
l'avez trouvé le oui il est interdit
d'interdire c'est une chose qui en
revendique je vous dirais très
honnêtement que je ne sais plus mais
enfin lui dit que c'est moi je sais plus
comment séné cissé prévaut où nous
avions tout cas tout cas c'est pas né à
la sorbonne on sait pas ne lâcheront
importance hamas est persuadé que ces
pannes et à la souris douane on a dit ça
le matin on faisait enfin le dimanche
matin à l'émission à rtl et
et on a dit les plusieurs phrases on a
dit d'abord il est interdit d'interdire
mais on parlait par le l'a donc pas sept
ans est venu dans la conversation s'est
pas limité écrivent l'enterrement on l'a
dit aussi je suis ici par la volonté du
peuple et je n'en sortirait que quand on
m'a rendu mon imperméable un truc qui a
marqué aussi on a manner cette avanie je
suis alors plagistes léniniste de
toulepleu glissé vous mais ça ce n'est
pas un festival de cannes je suis
et qu'est ce qu'il y avait encore on en
a besoin a dit plein alors vous dites
dans ce bouquin toujours pas quelle
époque le écrit mais peu importe les
hommes naissent libres et égaux en
droits après ils se démerdent naissent
libres et égaux mais politiquement vous
dites je suis pianiste de gauche quoi
est-ce que c'est un revenu de tout ça
parce que on disait yann ift comme on
disait poujadiste alors évidemment yanis
de gérer pas dire que j'étais un
poujadisme de go je donne quoique on
sait que oui le phénomène artistes de
droite me laisse voilà alors on 71 là ça
se gâte pas du tout parce que ce film
était absolument génial vous faites tout
le monde il est beau tout le monde il
est gentil
puis après il ya toute la série alors on
va pas s'appesantir moyenne à vouloir
des sous les chinois à paris show
business et dans les années 80 dans le
même esprit
13h45 avant jésus-christ liberté égalité
choucroute qui était en 85 votre dernier
film comme comme réalisateur alors comme
producteur vous avez des soucis c'est le
moins qu'on puisse en dire si vous dites
le lendemain des succès mon producteur
m'a appelé pour me faire d'affectueux
reproche
j'ai toujours eu des problèmes avec les
imposer l'image pour pour les gens de
quelqu'un lorsque vous avez mal su gérer
vos affaires
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas payer vos
impôts vous dites d'ailleurs c'est très
drôle l'idéal serait de pouvoir déduire
ses impôts de ses impôts oui c'est à
dire que le problème c'est que pour
faire j'ai pas eu vraiment d'ennuis avec
les impôts
les gens ont dit que j'étais parti aux
états unis pour échapper à l'impôt c'est
pas le pays idéal donc en amérique on
retrouve vite en peine un faux pas du
tout une république bananière mais
simplement la difficulté c'est ce que
disent tous les gens c'est d'avoir des
impôts extrêmement lourd et d'être
toujours obligé de faire une fuite en
avant pour arriver à les payer sera dans
la rue donc on est obligé de continuer
alors qu' on aurait envie de s'arrêter
et les résultats seraient meilleurs
parce qu'on aurait plus de temps pour
préparer pour écrire pour faire cesser
plus que ne pas payer vos impôts était
victime du système qui vous oblige à
produire produire on les paie les impôts
toujours pas l autre jour je regardais
j'ai vu galabru la télévision une dame
lui disais mais pourquoi vous êtes pour
que vous continuez maintenant vous ne
vous arrêtez pas il a dit parce que je
dois payer moins d'impôts que j'avais en
face encore inédit une voix une phrase
formidable quand on vous dit c'est page
35 du bouquin du cherche-midi qu'est ce
que vous aimeriez laissez derrière vous
vous répondez des dettes
j'espère laisser des dettes mais le
problème c'est que les dettes en faisant
les on les donne en de la famille et des
sonneries malheur car si l'on peut pas
leur faire ça mais si je pouvais
effectivement cher à vide ce qui est
incroyable c'est vous c'est que
parallèlement à tous ces films dont
certains ont été beaucoup ont été des
succès et certains ont été excellents en
72 dans la carrière complètement
différente vous entendre vous obtenez le
prix d'interprétation à cannes pour le
film de pialat nous ne vieillirons pas
ensemble
alors quand vous parlez de ça vous dit
espèce de jeu pas si c'est de la
modestie ou si ces deux là vous dites il
suffisait qu'en fait quand je tourne et
sinon tout le monde a crié au génie
envers notre interprétation lui ouais il
s'excuse et que je baisse les yeux par
mois il suffit que je baisse les yeux
pour avoir été prise alors je regardais
mon texte sur les genoux il marmonné le
texte vous avez écrit sur les genoux et
tout le monde a crié au génie
c'est ce qu'on disait d'un des notaires
qui était un homme politique allemand
dont on disait qu'ils seraient jamais
donc qu'il était c'était une chose très
sérieuse
il connaît son boulot à coeur en fête
dès noël avait eu les zygomatiques coupé
par un éclat d'obus de chars en ont pris
d'ailleurs comment un éclat d'obus pour
couper les deux mais enfin bon et il put
l'arrivée pas sourire à l est pas et moi
c'est la même chose les gens
dit sourit je sais pas si c'est à cause
de la barre beaucoup d'autres choses
plus selon rim plus j'ai l'air triste
donc en fait dans les scènes dramatiques
il suffit effectivement de fusionner
c'est vachement bien parce qu'on a
toujours envie de vous consoler oui
c'est bien mais en fait vous avez très
bien sa vie foot ça va très bien avoir
l'air triste ou avoir un chien alors à
la fin des années 70 vous partez à los
angeles en déclarant la section fait de
la porcelaine on va à l'image et sur
facebook
ce qui est assez logique fait un petit
crochet par new york que vous vous
retrouvez votre ami jean pierre rassam
qui produisait à l'époque warhol maurice
etc
et alors a los angeles vous intéresser
beaucoup au jeu télé aux séries télé
vous êtes les premiers le premier à vous
intéresser à questions pour un champion
est ce que vous croyez pas là vous avez
raté parce que c'est tellement de
possibilités on peut même pas dire vous
avez raté parce que vous avez fait
l'acteur vous avez fait la radio vous
avez hélas télévisée peut-être raté
parce que vous étiez là bas avant tout
le monde et vous aurez était maintenant
ils en font fortune en important des
idées des gens j'ai raté parce que
personne n'en a voulu
ouais c'est à dire que on a ramené 84
jeu américain l'idée c'était qu'en
arrivant là bas on n'avait pas les
moyens d'acheter les jeux qui marchait
très bien
donc j'avais dit je voudrais savoir
quels sont les jeux américains et
quelles sont les émissions qui ont été
faites depuis quarante-huit minutes à 60
alors on m'a donné plein de trucs est
géré à 20,84 jeu que j'ai proposé la
télévision à l'époque avec une seule
télévision et je me suis laissé filer
dans le
dans l'est on n'en a jamais voulu ils
ont été achetés ensuite parce que c'est
passé par londres parc on dit qui les a
vendus mais nous ils n'ont pas voulu
voir et le dernier truc que j'ai voulu
faire c'était le dja qui glisse une show
qui était quand même un truc tout à fait
étonnant jackie gleason étant un des
plus grands comiques qui avait obtenu
avant sa mort de faire de best of jack
et clé c'est à dire qu'il a viré tout ce
qui n'était pas bon il n'a gardé que le
meilleur j'ai eu les droits de ce truc
là je suis arrivé à paris et je suis
allé en personne a voulu j'ai rencontré
déjà 18 personnes à 23 il ya eu je ne
sais pas combien de choses et puis une
âme une ineffable dame qui a dit ça
s'appelle el hadi ne peut pas prendre ce
truc là parce que c'est pas en couleur
alors évidemment c'est sûr que l'on peut
pas prendre la relève vers leur nom à
prendre sur fall colorisées non mais on
n'a plus le temps mais c'est vrai que
votre les films que vous faisiez à
partir de tout le monde il est beau tout
le monde il est gentil ça aurait pu se
traduire un moment par la soie puis
devenir la télé ce style de cinéma
je vous demande si aujourd'hui il pas
plus adapté à la télé c'est ce qu'a fait
lederman avec les inconnus
c'est ce qu'a fait été fait avec pas là
c'est à dire que j'ai très bien pu soit
rapporté des jeux soit faire votre style
de film au cinéma
oui mais tout le monde avait dit moi je
pensais très sincèrement un moment je
disais ralala dans le temps j'étais à la
radio j et s'il y avait des radios
libres j'aimerais m'occuper de ça puis
après j'ai dit j'aimerais beaucoup
m'occuper d'une chaîne de télévision
puis un moment ça fatigue on dit oui
alors vous dites ça à vous dites parce
que vous avez une expérience à la télé
avec rires harira pas qui c'est qui
s'est pas très bien passé sur antenne 2
en 90 et vous dit tout à fait ça vous
dit je ne suis pas un battant je suis
pas tapie quand c'est trop dur je
m'arrête je me rate même avant que ce
soit trop dur je m'arrête quand c'est un
tout petit peu dur parce que c'est
perdre beaucoup de temps d'être en
battant 6 pendant des jours et des jours
il faut appliquer aux gens ce qu'on veut
faire
on fait plus rien donc il faut passer à
la chose en fait est ce que est ce que
votre
grand plaisir finalement c'est pas
d'être tout seul chez vous en train de
bouffer à poil dans toute crise il est
finale où il gère brouillard sur la mort
par à poil parce que j'ai un perroquet
qui vient sûrement les poulains griffe
mais autrement c'est vrai je suis je
suis bien je suis tranquille quand je
prépare mes petits une phrase l'une
faisant votre bouquin que j'adore
j'aimerais toutes les citer mais vous
dites plus beau compliment puissiez
faire à une femme c'est je suis aussi
bien avec toi que si j'étais tout seul
oui ça s'est vraiment engagé un truc
pour lui dire à une fille ouais presque
ces groupes bien je vous remercie
beaucoup voyez ça va vite un quart
d'heure j'aurais aimé vous gardez plus
souvent oui alors donc je répète le
titre du bouquin ses pensées répliques
texte et anecdotes au cherche midi et
celui de plomb s'appelle le sketch joué
injouable je l'avais etc merci beaucoup
jean yanne à bientôt j'espère ces gens
viennent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça va il ya un moment on
croirait qu'on est mort la dernière fois
vous êtes venu il ya quoi y'a un nom
pour un livre déjà un
on a tout raconté des gens à part
commencer vos riches fassent ça tout de
suite pour me [ __ ] la paix non non je
le fais je voulais le faire oui toute
façon la dernière fois vous êtes venu on
va parler de votre vie drogue la
prostitution
oui puis on avait parlé de votre
aventure avec
[Musique]
on va pas recommencer on va passer à la
promo directement vous êtes prêts pour
faire des petites mains là j'étais bien
il faut pas dire ah non c'est pas bien
mais faut rentrer dans le truc c'est que
vous êtes là oui pourquoi
pour faire la promotion d'un livre aux
éditions du cherche midi que j'ai écris
moi même et qui s'appelle je suis un
maître exquis alors c'est un recueil de
pensées d'articles de texte
extraordinaire comme tout ce que vous
faites toute façon depuis que depuis que
je vous connais le ton est donné dès la
page de garde vous dites je n'ai plus
aucun propos dignes de confiance
j'ai tout dit j'ai menti à tout le monde
je ne sais plus ce que j'ai signé qui
voilà comme ça au moins c'est clair non
c'est pas la peine de dire rage j'ai
plongé dans mes souvenirs
ce que je dis est sincère j'aime j'aime
ça je veux faire profiter le monde de me
de mes découvertes et de ma connaissance
jeudi je m'en fous c'est surtout ça vous
va bien d'un coût de 90 balles passées
aux éditions du cherche midi
voilà et c'est bientôt noël
[Applaudissements]
bien des cas si vous allez lire les
maximes que j'ai noté vous êtes prêts
oui page 14
l'amour est aveugle la preuve en le
faisant il ya des gens qui braille
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur des
convoyeurs de fonds 21 7 21 et celle
d'après cambronne ne mâchait pas ses
mots heureusement pour lui les bonnes
femmes sont toutes les mêmes elles nous
insultent parce qu'on arrive en terre
ils nous demandent pourquoi on n'a pas
appelé pour ne pas se faire insulter
deux fois de suite c'est quand on
commence à payer des pensions
alimentaires qu'on se rend compte à quel
point moi ça passe vite
je continue un peu ça va ils ont il faut
leur laisser un peu ses pertes et lâche
et plus la brenne ont fait pas ça mais
c'est puisque toujours un peu bébête
quand quand on est quand on raconte soi
même les trucs 87 87
je serais à la place des agriculteurs
qui dépose du fumier devant les mcdo je
me méfierais parce que les gérants vont
finir par croire qu'il s'agit d'une
livraison
[Applaudissements]
je
donc on va faire une petite interview a
redit view vous êtes prêts oui sur
[Musique]
la gauche parle
bien vous pensez à quoi là en ce moment
à rien je suis si je pense que j'ai que
je me suis précipité sur un petit bout
de pain avec du jambon de bayonne
en arrivant il vous reste sur l'estomac
n'ont jamais j'aurais dû avoir la
patience d'attendre pour la dînée
correctement voilà bah voilà quand vous
regardez le matin dans la glace vous
dites quoi
je regarde si je suis raccords pour la
barbe ah ah oui parce que si je peux
gagner encore un jour ça va mais si
c'est en tournage
jeudi mme banks a rien là j'ai une 2 mm
de plus alors j'ai du boulot non c'est
très difficile où un boulot non mais je
veux dire c'est aussi dur que ce sera
quand vous étiez petit vous auriez aimé
ressembler à qui n'importe quelle
arrivée votre plus belle histoire
d'amour
je n'aime que des belles histoires
d'amour je n'ai pas eu une plus belle
que l'autre mais beaucoup hein
un paquet aïe je regardais en préparant
les nations à ces normes
non mais c'est vraiment inquiet puis
défilent sublimons plus sublime pourquoi
parce que je suis honnête rixe qui a
montré le bout car comme on dit que
c'est très risqué
alors quand on vous demande des
autographes vous écrivez quoi ah bah ça
dépend en principe j'écris toujours dans
la rue ou sur un livre non dans la rue
au nom dans la rue j'écris bons
souvenirs dans les livres jeux
j'ai pas besoin de faire grand-chose jeu
mais c'est bien vrai et c'est au titre
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois je pleure uniquement à l'occasion
du mort ouais c'était qu'il a de tout le
monde est mort c'est que si vous voulez
j'ai fait une émission récemment avec un
type qui m'a mis devant une affiche de
tout le monde il est beau tout le monde
il est gentil cayzelle premier film
j'avais réalisé et qui me dit il ya
longtemps qu'il a vu cette affiche
et oui bien sûr et en temps et alors
qu'est ce que ça vous fait de le revoir
alors j'ai vu contre jean pierre rassam
et jean yanne présente jean pierre
rassam
exit way un scénario de gérard cyr et
jean yanne que gérard cyr ainsi que
michel magne plus de michel magne avec
bernard blier en huit mois vous
changeriez qu en vous si vous aviez une
baguette magique
mon ventre j'aurai des abdominaux comme
des plaques de chocolat je rêve de ça 1
ne me balader sur les plages et coeur
des gonzesses se précipite sur moi pour
avoir mal
[Rires]
vous trouvez comment bel homme bellone
way douillet c'est sympa au milliard 1
c'est sympa quand on n'est pas lui ça va
ouais non c'est vrai il ya un avantage
considérable à être alors ça c'est un
truc que j'ai pu observer son île fois
quand on est poilu et barbu on peut être
gros et habillés avec des choses
rigolotes oui c'est vrai vous points oui
mais janot carlos carlos éminemment
sympathique jean pierre coffe il voit là
il est gros bon ben c'est bien il à la
barbe
il peut se mettre des tee-shirts de
couleur des chemises hawaïennes bon vous
voyez pas je peins comme ça non
quel péché qui vous tente le plus jamas
l avarice parce que la varicelle un peu
le sait le seul péché qu'on peut avoir
même quand on est pauvre
[Rires]
jean yanne que diriez-vous de plus
négatif sur vos de plus négatif sur moi
vraiment pour vous auto iv c'est pour
mosley pour nous cela est maintenant
tout le monde est une fois pour toutes
j'aurais vraiment pu faire mieux
ouais ça c'est vrai moi je voulais dire
j'aurais vraiment pu faire mieux si je
n'avais pas été aussi flemmards mais en
fait même pas flemmard je n'ai jamais
jamais été un battant et donc d'accès
difficile je m'arrête
ouais donc je n'aurais jamais pu être
sportif ou franck leboeuf
moi j'aurais donné un coup de pied moi
un mec m'a effleuré le genou on en mange
trafic et le football de ces jeux c'est
exact vous avez dit j'ai un gros défaut
par rapport au sport je l'est aussi par
rapport à re spectacle je reconnais pas
les gens alors évidemment j'ai une
admiration sans borne pour les mecs qui
disent machin qui passe à machin qui
face à machin vous adorez thierry roland
oui parce que moi je vois un type qui
pousse un ballon qui donne un autre mais
qui donne un coup de ballon et puis j'ai
même pas vu comment ils font il met des
numéros sur le dos des gens à mon avis
il faut associer le même lit non
malandain et non un sujet qui avez vous
le plus envie d'épater monfils vous
feriez quoi s'il vous restait 24 heures
à vivre ce qui est bien c'est qu'en ce
moment cette question et c'est vraiment
gay votre avis sur le sait vraiment si
j'avais 24 heures je ferai pas grand
chose parce qu'en 24 heures je n'aurai
pas le temps de faire tout ce que j'ai à
faire et que j'aurais déjà dû faire mais
je crois que j'essaierai de
être avec eux les gens qui m'aiment bien
mais pas trop pour pas leur faire de
chagrin ouais je me ferai un petit
plateau télé
ouais je vais prendre un petit whisky et
je mettrai la téloche voilà voilà
c'est terrible c'est terrible alors que
vous ayez pas prier dans une église dans
un centre ville
je vais vous dire très franchement à 24
ans ça sert plus à rien j'ai fait de ma
gueule tu vas pas te repartir maintenant
24 heures
c'est vrai que dieu et comme vous c'est
ça le progrès il est beaucoup plus
miséricordieux
non pas du tout ce que dieu m'a fait à
son image c'est vous y serez surpris le
surnom qu'on vous donne que vous haïssez
non non moi ça me dérange pas les
surnoms de toute façon les on évolue on
les oublie lens qui me ce qui me ce qui
met ce qui m'énerve c'est quand les gens
alors moins - maintenant c'est quand les
gens me me tutoie dans la rue ils me
bouscule je ne paraît pourtant il ya
tellement de gens qui t'aiment non mais
ça dépend qui aussi je vois une fille
longiligne les bas à gainer de nylon
suif sétois s'approche de moi qui vit
dans un souffle
[Musique]
de quelle question aimeriez vous avoir
la réponse à l'affût revit enfin le soin
à part la mort c'est ce qu'il ya après
la wii un tiens quand on y mourut ce qui
nous énerve le plus en vo j'ai pas le
courage de 2,2 de dire non et les choses
qui m'emmerde à mourir dit bon allez
faire est-ce que vous énerve le plus
chez moi
non pourquoi non moi je n'ai pas
d'argent on peut tout se dire ce soir
non mais je sais bien mais moi non
pourquoi vous m'énervez pas moi c'est
vrai oh non c'est sûr oui je serais pas
venu gens c'est un nombre même un peu
oui non mais je même une certaine
passion par filise rien que parce que
j'aime bien que je sois toujours en noir
ouais ça te plait ça que je pense il a
démenti
[Applaudissements]
m - gay parce qu'on passe un e-mail
consacré à notre ami michaël blanc qui
s'est fait choper à bali avec de la
drogue
ils ont fermé et mais qu'il a pris
perpet pour 1 kg 8 de shit dans une
bouteille de plongée
non si on peut plus se mettre un kilo
idées reçues même temps il a plongé
alors où va t'on
[Rires]
c'est un mec était pratiquants shit mois
qui passaient les bouteilles de plongée
en seconde avaient attendu balle au chip
de 12 kg il mettait une bouteille c'est
pas joli non plus alors je voudrais
remercier les donateurs au nom de la
famille de michael blanc pour le moment
la famille a reçu 20 mille francs
alors j'ai trouvé un truc c'est que si
chacun est à peu près 2 3 millions de
gens qui regardent cette émission si
chacun donne un franc le type est sauvé
oui moi je connais bien mais moi j'ai
sauvé sauvé à ce qu'il faut bakchich et
pour le soir oui bien sûr moi j'y
retourne la valise donc avant la loi il
ya la prison de ne pas s'arrêter là
là faut fournir on pense qu'avec 1
millions 7,1 millions 8 voire 2 millions
on peut le sortir de là donc si chacun
donne en france beaucoup fait un chèque
d'un front l'adresse s'écrit en bas de
l'écran pendant que je le dis et l'ordre
ses soutiens michaël blanc voilà et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous il m'était impossible